[Musica]
buongiorno che figata bellissimo essere
qui e condividere questi piccoli dieci
minuti con voi gli eventi durano un po
di più però cercherò di darvi comunque
un po di energia e qualche
consapevolezza in più siamo in un posto
pazzesco c'è un'energia straordinaria
fatevi un applauso perché siete un
pubblico incredibile anche vedere tutti
questi ragazzi molto giovani qui grazie
iniziare questo vostro percorso iniziare
ad ascoltare queste cose così giovani e
bellissimo quindi ringraziate che vi ha
portato qui perché aveva fatto un dono
straordinario e rifacciamo un applauso a
chi ha avuto questa geniale idea allora
vi parlerò di ghiaccio e di acqua
partiamo da questo concetto che è un
concetto molto importante io cercherò di
trasferirli qualche consapevolezza
sull'amore l'amore che bello noi viviamo
per amare e per ricevere amore vero
viviamo per amare per ricevere amore e
soprattutto ricevere amore è una cosa
molto molto bella vero quando ti fanno
una sorpresa ti danno attenzioni ti
dicono qualcosa di bello di emozionante
molto bello fa molto piacere
solamente solamente che l'amore a volte
purtroppo e ne sa essere una cosa così
bella ma anche una cosa un pochino
fastidiosa o meglio molti credono che
l'amore faccia sa anche soffrire
l'amore sofferenza ho amato tanto allora
ho sofferto tanto avete mai sentito una
frase del genere
ho amato tanto quell'uomo amato tanto
quella donna e poi a causa di un suo
tradimento
ho sofferto tanto è mai capitato di
sentire una cosa del genere ci siete vi
è mai capitato di vadi interagire un po
questi dieci minuti quindi se vi è
capitato alzate la mano chi è capitato
ok vedete che c'era qualcuno
perché chi non ha sofferto in amore chi
non ha sofferto al caso di una relazione
ma anche di amicizia perché l'amore
anche verso i propri familiari i propri
genitori
i propri amici il datore di lavoro
i collaboratori al lavoro anche lì c'è
amore amore e donare qualcosa
amare è donare è perché c'è questo
bicchiere pieno di ghiaccio acqua e
ghiaccio
perché se questo bicchiere perché questo
bicchiere a tanto da insegnarci chi di
voi non ha mai bevuto un bicchiere con
dell'acqua e del ghiaccio tutti lo
abbiamo bevuto cosa accade quando
mettiamo un po di ghiaccio all'interno
di un bicchiere pieno d'acqua si
scioglie perfetto e che cosa accade
il ghiaccio fredda l'acqua giusto perché
l'acqua diventa più fredda vero no no
come daniele vero
il ghiaccio si scioglie l'acqua diventa
più fredda verissimo questo è quello che
crediamo superficialmente ma
profondamente e ce lo dice la legge di
entropia non lo dice di certo teneri di
benedetti non è il ghiaccio a donare il
freddo all'acqua più calda ma accade
l'esatto contrario mi seguite cioè è il
caldo che risiede nell'acqua a donare
quel poco calore che ha al ghiaccio
molto freddo
questo processo scalderà il ghiaccio e
di conseguenza nell'arco di qualche
minuto a volte di ore dipende dalla
quantità del ghiaccio si crede a un un
equilibrio tra il ghiaccio che si sarà
sciolto e l'acqua che prima era più
calda che cosa ci insegna questo
discorso che cosa ci insegna questa
legge pazzesca sono passati 3 minuti
cosa ci insegna questa legge pazzesca ci
insegna che se non è qualcosa da donare
se sei freddo
se non hai amore dentro di te non potrai
donarlo agli altri
se sei un cubetto di ghiaccio e vivi
come un cubetto di ghiaccio non potrai
donare qualcosa a qualcuno
se invece sei caldo come l'acqua allora
avrei qualcosa da donare
ma donare incondizionatamente senza
aspettarsi nulla in cambio
questo è il vero amore condividete con
me e condividere come che è molto
difficile vivere questa tipologia di
amore molto difficile perché perché non
abbiamo fatto un lavoro profondo su noi
stessi per lavoro profondo su noi stessi
intendo questa cosa
questo qui a un quadro di magritte molto
bello l'impero delle luci vi consiglio
di guardare i quadri di magritte perché
è stato un pittore illuminato e
straordinario come gli amanti ci sono
dei quadri che più li guardi e più
generalmente nuove consapevolezze
in questo quadro vediamo una cosa
straordinaria questo pittore un po pazzo
a mio avviso ha dipinto una scena di
notte perché la casa è di notte e
illuminata c'è anche un lampione acceso
quindi una classica scena notturna con
un cielo che è un cielo del giorno è un
cielo che possiamo vedere adesso scendo
qui fuori quindi probabilmente i critici
d'arte ovviamente odiano quello che sto
per fare però me piace generare
consapevolezza che sono utili alla mia
vita attraverso anche l'arte perché ti
permette di avere delle intuizioni e
quindi di creare qualcosa di tuo che poi
può donare a chi in questo momento a voi
amore incondizionato che sto donando
qualcosa una mia consapevolezza una mia
intuizione cosa intuito guardando questo
quadro bellissimo un'altra legge che non
lo intuita io è una legge che esiste che
si chiama legge di polarità che il primo
passo per amare incondizionatamente
ovvero accogliere tutto ciò che c'è in
questo quadro nella stessa immagine
nello stesso esatto momento c'è il
giorno e c'è la notte quanti conoscono
il simbolo del tao dove c'è il bianco da
una parte il nero dall'altra che si
abbracciano e nel bianco c'è un punto di
nero nel nero c'è un punto di bianco
quel simbolo un simbolo pazzesco di
grande risveglio di grande ispirazione
c'è il caldo e c'è il freddo come
abbiamo visto c'è l'inverno e c'è
l'estate c'è una persona alta c'è una
persona bassa
c'è una persona buona e c'è una persona
cattiva è che ha creato tutto questo
tubo e credere in dio può credere in
buddha può credere nell'universo in
un'energia superiore
credi in quello che vuoi adesso non è
questo è importante ciò che conta è che
chi ha creato tutto questo universo
straordinario
questo insieme di atomi lo chiamerebbe
richard feynman fisico premio nobel che
ci ispira tantissimo attraverso lecce è
spirato tantissimo attraverso delle sue
consapevolezze che ha creato tutto
questo non l'ha creato a caso così se
c'è questa contrapposizione e c'è
insieme il bianco e il nero è perché
deve esistere
quindi a mare tornare ad amare prima di
tutto noi stessi ea mare di conseguenza
la vita nella sua interezza nella sua
totalità significa amare tutto
tutto davvero che cosa intendo per tutto
davvero a quanti di voi hanno rubato
dentro il proprio appartamento o a
quanti di voi hanno magari rubato la
macchina il motorino insomma più o meno
nella vita
tanti di noi hanno incontrato nel loro
percorso persone che le hanno rubate può
capitare è vero magari avete degli amici
che sono stati derubati
la cosa che mi sto per dire ora è molto
forte
sedetevi bene attenti a non svenire è
molto forte ma di grande ispirazione
se vogliamo vederla con gli occhi di
persone un pochino più risvegliata con
gli occhi di una persona che ha capito
profondamente che il tutto è giusto che
esista è giusto che esista un ladro che
viene a rubare dentro casa sicuramente
ti fa dei danni sicuramente ti toglie le
cose preziose a me hanno rubato quando
ero ragazzino sono entrati in casa dei
miei ci hanno tolto tutto se anche
gioielli della comunione del battesimo
quelle cose che ti rimangono magari per
una vita che ti hanno regalato persone
che ami sparito tutto quanto è
ovviamente non avendo queste
consapevolezze cosa fai
giudichi c'è il giudizio c'è l'accusa
c'è rancore c'è la rabbia c'è l'odio
anche a volte però in quel momento non
sto accogliendo il tutto certo non è che
devo farmi venire a rubare a casa e
lasciare le porte aperte vai venite
perché dibenedetto ha detto che dobbiamo
accogliere il tutto ovviamente non
dobbiamo vivere così
ma quando capita qualcosa che non è
proprio in linea con ciò che per noi è
giusto dobbiamo ricordarci
le cose in modo un pochino più profondo
che il ladro che sta avvenendo a rubare
dentro casa
ermete diceva come in alto così in basso
gesù come in cielo così in terra un
ladro che sta facendo un'azione agli
occhi di molti negativa brutta per cui
potrebbe anche essere arrestato dovrebbe
essere stato per la legge
in realtà se la vediamo con occhi più
profondi come in alto così in basso come
in cielo così in terra portando queste
qualità basse di una persona che sta
rubando sta facendo qualcosa di brutto
per la società in alto beh innanzitutto
noi a detta di buddha stiamo lavorando
su una delle cose più importanti su cui
possiamo lavorare nella nostra vita e
che è la causa di sofferenza numero uno
l'attaccamento alle cose l'attaccamento
agli oggetti l'attaccamento alla
reputazione l'attaccamento alle persone
il ladro che sta facendo una cosa brutta
per te ti sta privando dei progetti ti
sta aiutando a lavorare su una cosa
profondissima condividete mi seguite
certo non vado lì a ringraziarlo
assolutamente di raccontare altre storie
ma adesso non ho tempo non vado lì a
ringraziarlo ha sicuramente posso fare
un lavoro su di me anche grazie a quel
ladro che mi ha rubato dentro casa
allora sto evolvendo come persona sto
diventando una persona migliore
e sto accogliendo tutto ciò che c'è
anche perché se giudico quella persona
per la legge dello specchio un'altra
legge pazzesca e questa legge ci dà
delle sportellate forti c'è una
consapevolezza molto potente perché
quando a di qualcosa profondamente di
qualcuno ricordati e non lo dico io lo
dice la legge dello specchio che se o di
qualcosa di qualcuno significa che in
the inte c'è qualcosa che rivede in
quella persona e allora lo odi e allora
gli dà addosso
allora lo giudichi provo a immaginare
tu sei davanti allo specchio in bagno ti
specchi e vedi un brufolo hai un brufolo
così in fronte sbam
cosa fai lo schiacci sullo specchio o lo
schiaccio su di te cosa fai lo schiaccio
sullo specchio dice ma non si schiaccia
sul suo specchio non capisco
inizia a dare testate allo specchio no
cosa fai lo schiacci su di te quindi
quando vedo qualcosa che non va in
qualcun altro devo sempre ricordarmi ma
forse c'è qualcosa in me che mi fa
sentire questo fastidio quando ti
sorpassa 1 tu sei in fila alle poste da
un'ora
hai fatto un'ora di fila arriva uno che
ti passa avanti
cosa ti dà fastidio che se li da un'ora
da aspettare quello di passo avanti o
che anche tu probabilmente profondamente
avresti voluto essere furbo come quella
persona forse sono cose su cui
riflettere ogni tanto anche perché se
giudichiamo e creiamo odio rabbia
rancore verso le cose che non ci
piacciono della vita non accogliendo il
tutto non amando la vita profondamente
lo dice un'altra legge che legge di
conservazione della massa che nulla si
crea nulla si distrugge tutto si
trasforma
quindi noi quella cosa che non ci piace
dobbiamo prenderla e trasformarla in
qualcosa di buono come il ladro che
viene a rubarci dentro casa perché se
prendete un foglio e gli date fuoco non
lo potete distruggere diventerà
qualcos'altro
tutto può diventare qualcos'altro ma
nulla si può distruggere hai una paura è
un in sicurezza
non potrei mai cancellarla ma io ogni
volta che devo salire qui sopra me la
faccio sotto non posso cancellare quella
paura ma posso trasformare l'energia in
amore verso di voi questo dobbiamo
imparare a fare facendo questi passi
evolutivi importanti anche perché se
iniziamo a vibrare energie diverse ce lo
insegna il diapason tenderemo ad
attrarre per la legge dal trazione
un'altra legge pazzesca energie simili a
quella che stiamo emanando quindi se tu
sei in un'energia dove vibri odio vb.ly
rancore verso qualcosa che ti è capitato
di ingiusto e mi dispiace anche a me son
capitate situazioni a storie molto
difficili nella mia vita che mi hanno
portato per fare quello che faccio oggi
avevamo tempo ovviamente ho imparato ad
accettarle quando imparato ad accettarlo
ido nuovi significati questo significato
è diventata energia energia positiva che
mi ha permesso di attrarre persone
migliori intorno a me che mi ha permesso
di aiutare i miei familiari
le persone che amo semplicemente
attraverso il mio esempio senza dire
nulla
semplicemente attraverso il mio esempio
diventando congruente con ciò che
credevo profondamente e poi per
concludere non abbiate paura di donare
il vostro amore perché quando lavori su
di te quando inizia a generare queste
consapevolezze
ricordati che sei come una candela una
candela quando accendo un altra candela
aiuta un'altra candela a fiorire ad
illuminarsi non perde la sua luce certo
possiamo andare su una candela a
soffiarci e spegnerla e della morte e
non possiamo scappare mi dispiace
possiamo fare tutti gli scongiuri che
vogliamo ma tutti avremo quel destino
però possiamo arrivare a quel destino
che abbiamo tutti in comune da persone
più risvegliate da persone più amorevoli
da persone che abbracciano la vita nella
sua totalità da persone che sanno essere
grato e totalmente di tutto ciò che gli
capita di persone che sono un esempio
per gli altri oppure di persone che sono
parte del problema e viviamo un periodo
un periodo storico molto critico i
giovani che sono stati lì il loro futuro
sarà un futuro particolare sono un
futuro di grandi cambiamenti dove tanti
lavori che loro genitori fanno non ci
saranno più quando loro saranno grandi e
si troveranno in difficoltà il mondo il
mondo sta cambiando sta cambiando in
modo radicale
ce ne siamo accorti poi quando capitano
queste cose come l'incendo in amazzonia
tutti a parlare dell'incendio nazione ma
dobbiamo iniziare da amare di più noi
stessi per amare il mondo per fare la
raccolta differenziata per non sporcare
per rispettare la natura
condividete quindi iniziamo ad amare noi
stessi accogliendo tutto ciò che c'è e
facendo chiudo con questo con questo
quadro di chagall che si chiama la
passeggiata
vi consiglio di guardare questo quadro
in un momento in cui siete rilassati e
di guardarlo attentamente perché in
questo quadro c'è tanto significato
questo quadro secondo me l'amore
incondizionato una persona che dona
senza nemmeno guardare la sua donna e
come vedete a un uccello in una mano e
nell'altra mano non la regge come per
tenerla ma è una mano appoggiata come
per lasciarlo andare e non si vede
nemmeno l'altra donna che sta dando
amore perché a volte to doni amore ad
una persona e quella persona non si
terrà l'amore indietro non ti darà il
suo amore in cambio però la vita
all'universo di obuda metterci quello
che più ti piace
te lo farà tornare prima o poi grazie
[Musica]